thousands of public sector workers
protested in Paris they say they're
overworked and underpaid and they're
angry at the French government's plans
to reform the pension system and raise
the retirement age something they say
would erode their rights
I started working very young and I'm fed
up and very tired and all around us our
young people in their 20s who can find a
job so I should be able to retire so
they can work I can enjoy a few years of
my life while still in good health
we can barely survive we can't pay our
electricity bills at some point our
salaries have to increase
the French government says that it's
doing all that it can to Shield people
from inflation but it won't back down on
its pension reform plan that it says
would make the system fairer
we will also Implement a pension reform
we can do it in a fair way at a
reasonable Pace we can guarantee this
reform will be effective if we allow it
to finance our social protection system
there have been a number of smaller
and Strikes over the rising cost of
living in France over the past few
months but this one is by far the
largest with workers from across the
public sector and what trade unions says
unless their demands are met it will not
be the last and that is the point of the
strike of today it's not an end in
itself I hope it is going to be the
start of an upsurge in the coming winter
of strikes and resistance all across the
different workplaces in France
French president Emmanuel macron has
wanted to reform the pension System
since his first term but pushing it
through now is clearly a risk at a time
when so many people feel that their
lives are hard enough Natasha Butler Al
Jazeera Paris